تم الترحيب بأربعة رواد
فضاء بوفرة حيث انضموا إلى
رواد الفضاء السبعة الموجودين بالفعل في
محطة الفضاء الدولية
لمدة ستة أشهر في حفل ترحيب ، وأنا
متأكد من
أنكما أتمنى أن تتم دعوتكما لمزيد من
المعلومات في هذه المهمة التاريخية cnn's
rachel crane هي  في كيب كانافيرال في
فلوريدا
حيث أطلق طاقم سبيس إكس التنين الفضائي
صباح أمس يومًا كبيرًا
في طاقم الفضاء 2 بنجاح
وأمان في محطة الفضاء الدولية
الآن يمكنك أن ترى أنها كانت مناسبة سعيدة للغاية
حيث تم الترحيب بأربعة رواد فضاء على متن الطاقم الثاني.
رواد الفضاء السبعة الآخرون الموجودون على متن
محطة الفضاء الدولية
الذين رفعوا إجمالي عدد
رواد الفضاء إلى 11 رائد فضاء ، لذا فهو في الواقع
مزدحم جدًا هناك الآن ، ولكن كما ترون ،
كان الجميع يبتسمون ويعانقون
زملائهم من رواد الفضاء سعداء
جدًا برؤيتهم يصعدون إلى
محطة الفضاء الدولية
خلال حفل الترحيب هذا يتم
الإطلاق الآن من مركز كينيدي للفضاء
ومن فلوريدا
كان الأمس تاريخيًا للغاية ،
وذلك لأن
كلاً من محاولة المركبة الفضائية وكذلك
المرحلة الأولى من صاروخ فالكون 9
كانا عبارة عن أجهزة أعيد استخدامها ، مما يعني
أنهما قد طاروا بالفعل إلى الفضاء ،
لذا في الوقت الحالي ، حيث تم إرساء المسعى إلى
محطة الفضاء الدولية ، حيث أعاد
النظر فيها.
لكن جزء إعادة الاستخدام هذا هو أمر
تاريخي حقًا هنا لأن
الهدف النهائي لـ Spacex's و Elon Musk هو جعل
الحياة
متعددة الكواكب ومن أجل القيام بذلك ،
يتعين عليك
تقليل تكلفة استكشاف الفضاء
وجزء كبير من ذلك  التكلفة هي
الأجهزة ، لذلك من خلال إعادة استخدامها بالطبع ،
فإنك تقلل هذه التكلفة
ولم يفعلوا ذلك مطلقًا في مهمة
بدائية ، وقد أعاد Spacex استخدام معززات الصواريخ الخاصة بهم
لبعض الوقت الآن
في الواقع ، لقد طار أحدهم بالفعل تسع مرات
ولكنهم لم
يفعلوا ذلك أبدًا  بمهمة بدائية ، لذا فإن سبيس إكس
وناسا يضعان النظام
الداعم للصاروخ وكذلك
المركبة الفضائية من خلالك تعرف آلاف
الاختبارات التي يسمونها بارانو  اختبارات IA
للتأكد من أن المركبة الفضائية
كانت آمنة لتحليق هذا الطاقم ولكن كما رأينا
اليوم
في الواقع ، فقد رست بأمان في
محطة الفضاء الدولية
كما أشرت إلى أنها مزدحمة للغاية
هناك الآن ولكن هذا سيكون فقط
من أجل  بضعة أيام لأن
الطاقم
الذي صعد إلى محطة الفضاء الدولية
منذ حوالي ستة أشهر
من المقرر أن ينطلق هنا على الأرض
وتناثر مثير للغاية يوم
الأربعاء بالطبع الطاقم 2 لرسو السفن الآن ، لقد
بدأوا للتو
رحلتهم بالفعل.  البقاء هناك لمدة
ستة أشهر لإجراء جميع أنواع
البحوث والتجارب المثيرة التي يزيد
عددها عن 250 منهم
لتحسين الحياة هنا على الأرض ،
وأنت تعلم أيضًا أن جزءًا كبيرًا من هذا نأمل
يومًا ما أن يعيدنا إلى القمر
وغدًا لذلك الكثير من  العمل الذي
يقومون به هناك هو كل هذا
الجهد